all things are possible if you believe
who we kind of understand is we're
treating our life for our goals
literally trading our life I believe
when you wake up you should get up the
second you wake up get your feet hit the
floor move into action
need motivation like you can with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being absolutely broke and dropping
out of school to reading Napoleon Hills
Think and Grow Rich turning his life
around and being a Law of Attraction
expert he's Bob Proctor and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
volume for all so if you want to know
what Bob and other entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my to 54 confidence
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below I was reminded this morning of a
question I'm often asked how do you
eliminate fear from your life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one move into action you know Don Shula
they coach of the old my Miami Dolphins
he said it's the start that stops most
people and he's right it is the start
the stops most people they're always
gonna get ready to get set to get going
what we've got to do is boom just like
that move into action see if you don't
get started you're never gonna get
finished how do we do that start early
I believe when you wake up you should
get up the second you wake up get your
feet hit the floor move into action and
you know you'd be wise if you sit down
at night before you go to bed and write
down six goal achieving activities
now that doesn't go to the store go to
the bank or get to cleaning it's not
that these are goal achieving activities
write down six of them and when you wake
up in the morning you move into action
you know where you're gonna go you don't
even have to think about it step in
actually get on the first one when you
get it done forget it and go to the
second one don't think about the first
one focus on two don't even think about
three when you get to then go to three
but not come off one at a time if you
don't get them all done just move them
over on to the next day and that doesn't
mean if you only get three done that you
have nine the next day there are three
of the six that you're gonna do the next
day six goal achieving activities and
when you wake up in the morning move
into action on them quit holding
yourself back don't wait and say well I
really don't know how I'm going to get
started and the way will show itself it
just appears I have found when you get
started when you move into action
everything starts to happen around you
rule number two have a strong why I have
worked all over the world I mean all
over Asia China South America and North
America Europe and I'm always asking
people what do you really want and I
have found most people don't want to be
really wealthy what they do want is they
don't want to have any financial concern
if they want to bind their suit they can
go and get one if they want to take a
trip they can take the trip if they want
a new car they can get the new car they
don't want to just run out and spend or
buy they don't want to have any
financial concerns - they want to wake
up in the morning excited about how
they're gonna spend their day and the
third they want to mix with people who
are upbeat and creatively productive
these are the three things that people
really want so in answer to your
question if somebody's watching what's
the first thing they should do well the
first thing they should do is understand
why we have goals not just to set a goal
because most people don't set goals
right they they're operating with a
limited level of consciousness so
they're thinking hmm if I could get a
little more money and if I could get him
to help me and her to help me and this
happened then I could do this maybe this
is get a new car but we kind of
understand these we're treating our life
for our goals literally trading our life
would you trade your life for a car or a
house I don't think so so it's got to be
something really meaningful and we're
not taught to think this way we should
sit down and don't give any thought to
where the money is gonna come from where
the help is gonna come from it's what do
you really want like ed Hillary was a
beekeeper in Auckland that's right he
wanted to climb Mount Everest it had
never been done great people died trying
to do it he went in 51 and failed he
went back in 52 and failed in 1953 he
stood on top of the mountain with
Tenzing Norgay but he didn't know how to
get there until after he had got there
Edison didn't know how to illuminate the
world
until after he had done it the Wright
brothers were bicycle mechanics in
Dayton Ohio no one believed he could fly
they'd been trying it for years but they
saw it but they wanted to do it they
didn't know how and they couldn't tell
you until after they had done it now the
first flight only lasted 12 seconds and
the naysayers said yeah but they only
were up there for 12 seconds they said
we not only got up there we kept the
damn thing up there for 12 seconds so
when a person sets a goal they've got to
say look what I want if I just let my
mind roar off just wander use my
imagination how do I really want to live
that's what they should be doing rule
number three start with a vision most
people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want we've got to
consciously and deliberately imagine
what we do want if we will take and sit
down with a pen and ask ourselves what
do I really want what do I really want
and write it down and then make a
written description of it in the present
tense writing causes thinking thinking
creates an image and you get these
images going you're building a vision in
your mind it's the visionaries that's
changed the world think of that the fact
that I can sit and look into this camera
and you can sit and look at me on your
phone or on your TV or on your laptop
that was the result of somebody's vision
do you know everything you've got the
clothes you wear the house you live in
this microphone that's in front of me it
was all a result of somebody's vision
it's not an accident you and I have a
marvelous imagination
and everything starts with a vision van
Gogh is asked how he did such beautiful
work he said first I dream my painting
and then I paint my dream rule number
four improve your self-image
you know dr. Maxwell Maltz wrote a book
back around 1960 it was called
self-image psychology psycho-cybernetics
it's a phenomenal book he said it was
the greatest discovery of his generation
he was a cosmetic or reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have been a nose job or
removed a terrible scar and he noticed
that when he did that there was a
phenomenal change in their personality
but he noticed through the others he
would make a phenomenal physical change
and there was no change in their
personality and that led him to
postulate that we have two images we
have the one that's coming back from the
mirror but we've got an inner image and
that inner self-image is literally
controlling our life you will find
people that have a very poor self-image
or low self-esteem they won't look you
straight in the eye they're afraid to
shake hands with you they're very shy
and withdrawn they go through life
hiding from life they don't like
themselves they don't know themselves do
you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationships
change their health changes and you know
how you do that start studying you start
to find out more about you there's
something phenomenal about you you know
when I began to study this material 57
years ago I am very poor self-image I
had low self-esteem
I took dumb jobs I never earned any
money I never had fun I had poor
relationships and as I started to study
started to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
I've got friends all over the world
today I earn millions of dollars I'm in
my 80s and I get as much energy as a
person in their 30
you see when you start to understand
really who you are you're God's highest
form of creation there's things about
you that just about blow your mind as
you start to study and really understand
them you'll walk a little taller
you'll stand a little straighter and you
know something you'll enjoy a whole lot
more of life rule number five develop
self-awareness I've got to wake up you
see all we're ever gonna get is
awareness we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got we're God's highest
form of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will equal us well that's
all right that's all any of us are after
that's all the problems in the world
come from maintenance that has a purpose
of life overcome ignorance develop
awareness the only way to overcome
ignorance is through knowledge and the
only way to get the knowledge is to
study most people they finish school
cause the books that I have got a desk
over I'm never going to open another
book as long as I live
it's screwed it's all over rule number
six make decisions you know Napoleon
Hill and thinking Grow Rich wrote an
entire chapter on decision most people
never make decisions they have a
difficult time with it why is that I
think they have a difficult time because
their parents made decisions for them
until they were too old and they never
learned how to make them you know the
one thing that I did with my kids I
never made a decision for them they
didn't like it they'd say come on don't
do that to me I said no what do you
think you should do and I'd leave it at
that decision-making is a phenomenal
concept and you're going to find out as
he points out in here the successful
people make decisions very fast and they
change them very slow if and when they
change them at all and he said the
people that have difficulty in life make
their decisions very slow and then
change them fast and often and you know
decision making is a funny thing you and
I think on frequencies if we could see a
bunch of lines and we're thinking on a
frequency and we're on this frequency
here and we're saying I'm going to do
that when this changes this is never
going to change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you've got to get your mind
up there how do you get up there make
the decision be there and that's really
what you have to do the second you make
a decision you flip your brain onto a
different frequency and you start to
attract things to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision rule number seven get out of
the box see someone woke me up that's
all I want to do with someone else what
the man said to me the first guy he said
you can have whatever you want
well you know there you're thinking that
you can get out of the box that's where
you've been given an imagination to get
out of the box it's with your
imagination that you build the images of
what you want and if you can build the
image you can do it you can hold it in
your head you can hold it in your hand
when we understand that like I would
imagine this goes out to a lot of
athletes as well they can they can have
anything they want they got to pay the
price
and when don't comes in check it out you
can't afford the doubt rule number eight
grow yourself if I want to do something
I find somebody that's already done it
and then I do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow i I don't
read novels I don't watch movies and I'd
watch documentaries or things like that
where I can learn I'm only interested in
studying something that can cause me to
become more of what I'm capable of being
see I think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with their life
and
that's all I want to do hmm
I'm really good at what I do I could
walk by a person in the hall like that I
could tell them exactly what they're
like I could read their energy like a
book everything goes on the inside shows
in the outside
see we're gifted with with faculties of
the mind that the average person knows
nothing about you have intuition the
will reason imagination perception
memory that's what separates us from all
the rest of forms of life we go through
school never learn anything about it but
you'll hear people say they have a bad
memory there's no such thing as a bad
memory everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it our imagination your imagination is
the most magnificent piece he'll said
it's the most marvelous miraculous
inconceivably powerful force the world's
ever known I can use my imagination to
project myself into the future and bring
the future into the present and start
living there you work from the
imagination you don't work to it you
work from it backwards from the result
yeah rule number 9 surround yourself
with greatness
you know the people you surround
yourself with have had a phenomenal
impact on your life I think it was Karl
Menninger from the Medicare foundation
one time said environment is more
important than heredity the people were
surrounded by have a greater bearing on
our life and our success in life then
what's built into the genes at Birth
there's genetic conditioning there's
environmental conditioning well this
environmental conditioning goes on all
the way through life you will find as
you improve the quality of your life
improve your thinking you're going to
attract a different group of people into
your life and they are going to add to
your life see the people were surrounded
by their thinking is going right into
our mind we want to mix with people who
are really making it happen take a look
at your five people that you're with
most often and ask yourself if I have
children what I want them to grow up be
like them if the answer is No
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what I'm saying
the people were surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on my life and helped
make us who we are and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is believed William James from
Harvard said believe and your belief
will create the fact all things are
possible if you believe well you know I
studied for a long time I started to
study this book Think and Grow Rich and
he talks about belief in here he says
you're not ready for what you want until
you believe you can get it I found that
the only two sources of reference we
could go to to find out anything about
herself is science and religion they all
say you've got to believe so I get
figuring out how do you how do you
believe how do you change a belief
interesting subject because I'm going to
tell you something your results are
nothing but the manifestation of your
belief system
well our belief system now listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
reevaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change and we repeat
that our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something frequently if we
reevaluate a situation our belief about
it will change
I began reevaluating who I was I started
to study I never stopped studying and I
found as I really waited I had a much
higher opinion of myself I found out
things about me that I would have never
believed if you had told me the power
that's locked up within us the marvelous
system we've got do you know the blood
circulates through your veins every 33
seconds through hundreds of miles of
passageway dying just like that colors
all the food in and all the garbage out
stop and think of the central nervous
system it's the most complex electrical
system in the world and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around
we have awesome powers and so based on
what you believe about you
now I've got a really special bonus clip
on how to change from the inside that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what do you need to believe more in
number two how can you surround yourself
with that more daily and number three
how can you move into action audit
immediately
however once your desire has been firmly
established it is the expectant attitude
that ensures your goal or dream is not
uprooted or replaced by any opposing
idea to see when you understand how this
power works and your conscious
relationship to it you're not going to
be knocked off track by circumstance
because you are expecting the right
thing to happen like Paul HUD C said he
said I found the 1080 Kerr lot because I
was looking for the 10 acre lot
most people don't expect it they just
think because they changed vocations
they changed towns they've changed
spouses they've changed clothes they've
changed cars that everything's going to
happen uh-uh you don't change the
kitchen by painting the outside of the
house if you want your results to change
permanently and dramatically you've got
to change them inside the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon
[Music]
if you want more Bob Proctor check out
the how to change your paradigm video
that I made on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
when you're going to add the only thing
you can measure is what you're giving up
whatever watch coming you know what's
coming what you want